european league of legends
changed in 2021 the mad lions with baron
are pushing inside the base oh caps is
so low he's going for the kill but it's
a resurrection and a shutdown for karzi
he slays g2's mid laner
titans fell history has been made
neither fanatic
nor g2 will be in a european final
challengers
rose they want to get things going
trippy in the midst of everyone but he
gets stunned he gets locked up the
shotgun
is still alive trippy just barely
getting shut down and matt lyons getting
crushed in the fight
and a new era began just not the one
anyone expected
10k gold lead mad lions push forward
just looking for it
that'll slow and low shock wave
is huge humanoid may have just done it
as designers has a block of everybody
it's kind of leaping into the backline
arm but but still hot topic larson alive
for now oyo trying to do what he can and
his armor
with the follow-up the divers from the
side of mad
are unstoppable but it's within touching
distance for both these two teams
caught out kaiser whips the engagement
it's inspired in the middle of
everything but is it too little too late
one that tries to find a way to the back
side but it won't matter into the two
the two time tcl champion
makes his mark on this final and mad
lions are not done yet it is han sama
running for the hills it is rogue
falling down
in the final moments matt lyons may end
it right here
against all expectations against all
predictions
mad lines against all odds
before we talk about madeline's
incredible spring split
you should know a little bit about their
history first ever since they were known
as splice
madd has never really overperformed
they've been a solid
middle of the pack team and even picked
up a decent world's performance once
but the players on the team have always
had bigger goals
to take down the giants of europe ng to
a full back
that's a big stun that's a big engage
oh my gosh look at the fight they look
for kill number four
this might be an ace inside of the base
inside of 18 minutes
the mid inhibitor will surely fall this
is what
peak league of legends looks like and it
comes
from europe 10 splits eight titles
g2 are the greatest team we have
ever produced in europe and they go back
to back to back to back and win the
summer season g2 esports is considered
the best western league of legends team
of
all time they've won eight lec finals in
the past five years
placed second at world 2019 and became
the first western team to
ever win msi they've been considered
unbeatable in europe
and going into 2021 very few teams had
ever made them bleed
the rookies have risen up the defending
eu champions in g2 esports are on their
back legs
there's no ways there's no ways five
members are down they've done it
it's the mad lions they have unseated
the champions they have killed the kings
in the 2020 spring playoffs madd managed
to knock g2 into the losers bracket with
a close 3-2 win
but g2 bounced back quickly and
eliminated mad a few days later
g2 esports have had to fight hard today
but they will set themselves up for the
final the nexus is the focus
g2 eliminates the mad lions
and set themselves up for another fight
with fnatic in the finals
and g2 come back with a strong look here
one day before those finals a lot of
people have fnatic pinned as the
favorites but g2
showed some good fights here today
against the mad lions that did not
give easily we're gonna have one hell of
a best of five tomorrow trevor
madd still went to worlds that year but
they had a historically bad performance
they were eliminated by supermassive
esports and became the first
team from a major region to ever bomb
out of worlds during the play ends
they could smell blood in the water
supermassive know that they've got him
on the ropes it's just
within touching distance a single nexus
as cacao will drop
but so will the mad lions tcl are facing
unicorns but on the other side of the
rift
an unlikely alliance was beginning to
form our roster kind of didn't work
at a at a really high level like at a
top tier level you know because we felt
like we would never be champions of
europe with that roster
and we felt like there was something
something missing and that in order to
reach that level we had to take
risks and mac madeline's coach found his
champion
in a former rival armet has been one of
the best turkish league players for
years
with back-to-back world appearances on
two different teams and
three tcl championships to his name it's
clear that he'd accomplished everything
a league player could in turkey
but armit wanted more after beating them
they told me they were interested in me
which was i was really happy about it
because
it was time for me to move on from tcl
to major regions
so i was definitely going to e or n a
but then i mean i got many offers but
medlines into my eye like they were the
top three best team in eu
so i like okay i'm coming to medlines
so armit wanted things that the tcl just
couldn't offer
meanwhile mad wanted to bring down g2
and end the reign of europe's arrogant
gods
the match seemed perfect but going into
2021
there were a lot of questions about mad
there are a lot of extra variables that
i think
hurt them at worlds last year but also
they weren't a very good team
they were very one-dimensional and um
they i think they already showcased in
playoffs they were the fourth seed for a
reason
see just like every other esport in the
world league went online in 2020 that
means that ping became a real issue
and stage jitters became a lot easier to
deal with mad performed well in 2020 and
even got that win over g2 in the
playoffs
but a lot of people just called it a
lucky online fluke
and when they bombed out of worlds the
year's only big land
the haters thought they were right mad
lions have accomplished a lot
and it's unfortunate that the taste that
will be left over
in fans mouth will be one of such
disdain
and disgust because of the performance
on a world stage
when everything surrounding it like
was obviously very volatile the fact
that mad lions really came into fruition
during the online stage of the lec
and then moving on to stage moving into
a different meta madd was also bringing
in some new blood for 2021.
armit was a veteran in turkey but he
just didn't have the experience playing
in a major region
and elioja the team's new jungler was a
rookie from the spanish minor leagues
with very little on stage experience
but max believed he was making the right
calls i
don't know if i call it a playstyle but
like a mentality right where
we're we're really high risk with the
way that we play the game and that's
something that i didn't want to
like jeopardize or i didn't want to put
a player in there who was like
the wrong type of player surprising no
one g2 placed first in the regular
season with a 14-4 record but
madd placed third with a respectable
10-8 however
hopes weren't high for matt in the
playoffs especially given their offline
reputation
dracos here is my playoff prediction
finalist for the top 6
g2 rogue mad lions sk
fanatic shalka no fear ender
auditioning 4 g2 rogue fanatic
mad shulker s k k joe's playoff
predictions
rogue g2 mad lines phonetic sk
anyway madelines were a beloved team but
most people thought that the finals were
going to be between g2
and rogue the second place team from the
regular season but
no one predicted what happened next
mad lines were obliterated in game
number one and on the precipice of a
back to back-to-back series
when han summer and lost it all on the
defense they're pushing backwards mad
lines have done it they've got lawson
they've not heard summer they've aced
rogue and mad lions will
have a rematch with g2
mad started the playoffs with an upset
taking a three to one win
over rogue but beating rogue was only
mad's first hurdle
the juggernaut was still ahead of them
it was time to put the theory to the
test
was mad just a covet-era fluke or could
they be something
more 41 minutes in he's got himself five
items completed
and the channel comes out from mickey
he's looking for backline access
jennifer
is interrupted by kaiser wonder's got no
hijack available he's taken out seljoya
that gets the kill but it is traded for
his own life
one for two two for three cause he's so
excited caps versus courtesy
g2 cap stays alive thanks to the buster
shot the mad lions with baron are
pushing inside the base oh caps is so
low he's going for the kill but it's a
resurrection and a shutdown for karzi he
slays g2's mid laner it is
mad lions in absolute control of this
game
absolute control of this series and they
set their sights on the nexus they set
their sights
on two they set their sights on their
first final a shocking
opening two games in this series where
nearly everyone predicted it to go the
way of g2 mad lions
had this happen to them last week
against rogue nk gold lead mad lions
push
it's huge humanoid may have just done it
he finds two it's set up by kaiser
every single mad lion today has
out matched their opponents every single
play
the mad lions have been able to put
together and set them up
for the 3-1 victory mickey runs for his
life the rest of madeline's pushing onto
the first
nexus turret mad lions onto the second
nexus turret and it's mad lions that
defeats
g2 and it's mad lions that qualify for
their first
ever final even if things ended right
there
madeline still would have proved the
haters wrong they took down g2
the gods of european league on lan it
was the real deal
but they weren't done yet g2 wasn't
eliminated they were just in the losers
bracket
they could still make a comeback or
could they
bro he could not be more poetic larson
overcoming his demons and removing
reckless from the equation with that
shockwave it's rogue all the way all
right caps is under a little bit of
threat yeah multiple members of rope are
low the hijack is not yet available
going gold in the first nexus turret
falls rogue turned their attention to
the second one
capps is trying to get some kills in the
backstop but he's down he's dead
history has been made neither fanatic
nor g2
will be in a european final and for the
first time rule will face
mad lions for the crown it was a
historic moment
rogue delivered the killing blow to g2's
hopes and ended an
era but now there was a new question who
would lead the new age of
european league no one was expecting mad
and rogue to face off in the finals
and for a while it seemed like madd just
weren't ready
now they're pulling the trigger again
with the tp still 20 seconds on the mid
jungle rogue might look for some
inhibitors
now you're gonna have to back off here
they can't afford to contest this one if
they die there's no way
to lose the game they have super minions
it might be over they have to be careful
though there's a top wave in this double
tp on the side of mad lines
but needs to get angry very fast ride
breaker forward but he just takes so
much damage his fire goes in because
he's still alive karzi firing back on to
inspire but that's hans off his ultimate
that's gonna be it they are but now
stepping forward he wants to hold on to
the base he won't stand
hard strike again 2-0
for rogue madd were on the ropes
down oda two in the series they needed
to pull something out of their hats
and that's when arma told his team to
trust him even it was trees bro
we couldn't have any more regrets you
know we had to call him like
that's what we were thinking all the
time and for armour going all
in meant locking in an unorthodox pick
wukong i think wukong is
definitely not a good champ right now
but like
i know the how to play bukong i mean i
know the game style how should i do it
wukong
and rock was just enemy team was just
picking the walrus and lucian that kind
of stuff that has like no mobility to
run
and they were 80 champions which is
wukong really good into it
so i just it's [ __ ] twice like let's
go for it you know
can they do what inspired ready to
interrupt el yo has to go and they know
they have to go for this but i'm not
waiting into the darkness the altitudes
though the ultimate spire does not
connect to han somebody though the one
that you need to watch
the leap back he dodges the shock wave
larson untouched mad lions have not
found the fight that they're looking for
but kaiser goes for the re-engage anyway
oh you'll be off the backside the flash
the stun
isn't enough on someone still alive
osama
shut down kaiser grabs the kill inspired
getting cut down where he stands and
rogue have to run for the hills
to walk away empty-handed yeah mad lions
are really trying to force a kill onto
inspired his flash was just about to
come up oh flash the immediate all
haunts i'm now in trouble that's gonna
be the second oh [ __ ]
look at the damage coming out from
armour indeed cadre quick kill picked up
by man
and we are on pace for mad lines
potentially win the fastest game
all day long with the momentum heading
into game five with two wins in a row
rogue as designers has a pause of
everybody it's kind of leaping into the
backline armour but still huntsman
larson alive for now oyo trying to do
what he can in his arm
with the follow-up the divers from the
side of man
are unstoppable humanoid there to finish
the job mad lions have done it
23 minutes into the game and i think
they've won absolutely no fear
in the eyes of the mad lions diving past
five players diving past
the inhibitor tower they wanted han sama
that's what they got
and we're going to game five after game
three armor stood up he knew
3-2 was what he hovered the absolute
confidence from mad lions to turn the
series back
to bring us to game five after putting
armour on wukong mad won the next
two games to tie up the series rogue
were forced to ban wukong for game 5 but
madd completed the reverse sweep anyway
it is so rare to see
a final in europe never happened before
without a g2 or a fanatic but it's
within touching distance for both these
two teams
hot out kaiser whips the engagement it's
inspired in the middle of everything but
is it too little too late
one that tries to find a way to the back
side but it won't matter into the two
the two time tcl champion
makes his mark on this final and mad
lions are not done yet it is han sama
running for the hills it is rogue
falling down
in the final moments mad lions may end
it right here
mad lions have the wave in mid there is
no stopping them
three games in a row the reverse sweep
becomes a reality
seven thousand gold deficit armored
snarks solidifies the win it's the nail
in the coffin
the waves there otto abney's trying his
best he's gonna fall
mad lions are gonna win it is not rogue
it is not fanatic
it is not g2 and the new era of european
league of legends
it is the mad lions oh it it still feels
really weird like
every day for the last three days i've
literally woke up every morning and the
first thing that's just
been in my mind just like did we really
win that game like how did we win that
game
like literally the first thing every
morning it's super super super surreal
thinking that like
we're actually like champions you know
mad may not have eliminated g2 but
they earned their land win both against
europe's old gods
and against their fellow challengers
rogue but now
they have a new challenge they're
representing their region on the
international stage
at msi they're the face of a new age of
european league
and the old gods have left them a long
legacy to uphold
okay boomers you want to see more we'll
hit our ceiling when you hit the
lips but they seem to floor their roster
slips reckless chances looking gloomy
can't win a title that captures
this is an assassination no more g2
domination no more kings no legacy
your rivalry is so outdated your history
now looking faded
eu fans we know you waited rogue and mad
now activated